écoutez c'est il serait temps que le
président de la république mesure dans
lequel la situation se retrouve le sport
amateur et professionnel en france
depuis plusieurs semaines nous sommes
nombreux avoirs mobiliers de
sensibiliser la ministre sans beaucoup
de résultat malheureusement lorsqu'on
voit les propositions qui sont
aujourd'hui présentées dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances s'est
quasiment ridicule et donc que luis il
était important que le monde de sportifs
professionnels et amateurs se mobilisent
que le président de la république est
pris aux milices entendre ce message et
j'espère maintenant qu'on aura des
propositions concrètes
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
on voit bien que le monde amateur est en
grande difficulté avec une chute du
nombre de licenciés avec des recettes
fortement en baisse donc des
propositions ont été ciblés sur les
fédérations mais trop faible dans le
projet de loi de finances c'est une
vingtaine de millions qui sont ciblés
sur les fédérations heureusement hier le
scénario soir le sénat rajouter 5
millions mais c'est pas la mesure de ce
qui attend les fédérations donc il faut
souhaitions fédération qui est de me
directement le monde amateur
donc c'est un effort important auprès
des fédérations je crois que le comité
olympique hachés frais ça a pu de plus
100 millions et à côté de ça aussi on a
le monde professionnel qui est en grande
souffrance avec des rencontres
aujourd'hui qui se joue à huit clos et
avec des clubs professionnels je parle
pas uniquement du foot 1 qui lui encore
peu bénéficié encore c'est un point
d'interrogation des droits télévision
mais tout le reste nous pour
professionnels
le rugby le basket ball le volley le
hand look et sur place ce sont des
sports professionnels qui en sont
aujourd'hui en grande souffrance parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de billetterie et donc
aussi il faut qu'on ait une proposition
aujourd'hui le gouvernement inscrit une
centaine de millions pour l'aide de la
billetterie dont vingt mille 20 % sur
les grands événements et 80 et quelques
lyon pour les clubs pros c'est pas
l'auteur là aussi des attentes
nous avons voté au sénat
un dispositif d'exonération des charges
sur les les matches qui se jouent à huis
clos avec une jauge à moins de 1000
spectateurs contre l'avis du
gouvernement j'espère que cette
proposition sera retenue par le
président de la république ou par
l'assemblée nationale
ce serait un bon signal de jean envoyé
au monde professionnel donc on voit que
sur tous les sujets qui touchent le
sport nous nous ça fait des semaines et
des mois qu'on alerte sans beaucoup de
résultats il faut le reconnaître ni
haine du côté de l'assemblée nationale
ni du côté du sénat là le monde sportif
s'est mobilisée le président de la
république monte au créneau
on la ministre aurait pu le faire
quelques depuis quelques temps pour le
sport amateur
quelles propositions vous avancez ou
parce que il ya une grande souffrance
il ya beaucoup de pays qui menace de
mourir qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
on a évoqué avec avec mes collègues mais
aussi avec la ministre
c'est la ministre même qu'il avait mis
un coup sous la tâche ce sujet un
passeport et l'air pour aider au prix de
la licence au financement de la licence
avec un montant qui pourrait être
définie et qui pourrait s'associer à des
êtres que font déjà certaines
collectivités et des départements et des
régions qui qui ont mis en place un
dispositif pour soutenir les familles
qui achètent une licence de sport
ok sur le principe je pense que ça ce
serait un bon signal
encore une fois malheureusement dans le
budget lorsqu'on interroge le ministère
le calendrier qu'ils espèrent mettre en
place et le cep troisième trimestre de
les mater donc pourquoi pas et moi je
pense que c'est une bonne solution
ce que concrètement il ya aucun crédit
qui est inscrit donc là aussi dans le
cadre d'une projet de loi de finances on
voit proposer des amendements ou on va
commencer à inscrire des crédits pour
envoyer un signal fort au monde sportif
et associatif pour la vie voilà l'état
travaille sur un projet passeport mais
en inscrire des crédits parce que si
c'est simplement pour faire des annonces
qui sont sans acte c'est je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les acteurs attendent
plus des discours mais les actes